50 millions par an sur trois ans gilles
et soussan millions là c'est le salaire
vous avez donné le salaire 150 millions
par an ouais ça fera 150 millions net
sur les trois ans et le real madrid
proposé sur cinq ans dans ce même chose
ça aurait été la masse et sa part qu on
a annoncé une prime à la signature de
300 millions parce qu'à pas de frais de
transfert c'est faux c'est pas rassurant
la spa sont complets exactement 100 ans
130 millions voilà c'est ça n'a pas 300
millions ça c'est plus de 60 millions
par an voilà et le real propose est
sensiblement la même chose mais ce n'est
pas une affaire d'argent ceci dit de
rester en france en dix ans aujourd'hui
c'est la france c'est mon pays et quand
gilles dit l'émir est entré dans la
danse c'est totalement faux c'est
emmanuel macron qui a fait un geste va
dire lilas il a dit se nommer attends
attends ton mais
il laisse parler des adultes parce qu'à
ce temps là les enfants évolution
est ce que tu vas dire que des conneries
qu'elle parlait de l'argent tu nies que
des bêtises alors il a sur trois ans ou
mal et là ça
c'est certain ben oui tu as la même
baisse depuis 12 ans
samedi gilles fages vous allez à la
finale de la ligue des champions real
madrid liverpool vous y aller ou pas oui
pourquoi pas des billets à vendre parce
que en 98 12 janvier
je peux tu expliquer je peux tu
expliquer sans fous j'ai été condamné à
10 mois avec sursis et 5000 euros
d'amendé tellement j'avais fait des
trucs tu dit observant mais quand tu
travailles dans des sociétés qu'un titre
chose que tu as jamais eu surtout que
toi tu as passé ta vie est journaliste
et à faire des fausses notes de frais
donc ta ta ta ta vraiment raison
d'attaquer
le parisien l'équipe le parisien et à
chaque fois on t'as demandé des comptes
tu as raison d'attaquer les autres là
dessus je suis
là messieurs
[Applaudissements]
5wasquehal
insultes auraient pas mais partons pas
du tout moi sa chute aurait permis aux
prud'hommes contre le brésil jamais
cette affaire a gagné aux prud'hommes tu
vas retrouver au chômage et à demander à
des gens de payer après le chômage jean
yves le masne on peut parler on peut
parler jour dossier reconnaît par
ailleurs seller de gilles verdez mais
moi je suis gentille qui soit la
canteraine pour faire un petit peu tu es
en train de te refaire c'est bien là et
celle de changer de veste est vraiment
différent avec les défis
écoute moi évident que dire des bêtises
invida bêtise dis moi ce que je veux
dire yaka truc que je vais dire il ya
tant que je comprends pas j'ai 70 ans
j'ai jamais été serein sur kinder et
tout fatou et vient de m'écrire c'est
lui connaît
[Applaudissements]
parce que ces démissions uk je suis un
vieux con mâché par ce côté singers et
wafa tout je voudrais te rencontrer à
21h15 après l'émission
c'est fatou je sais pas
ces dix jours des mauvais jours où je
vais me lever c'est mieux foutu elle me
lever tu vas voir ce que ça va ça sert
les faits du 20 mai me trois mois d'un
coup leur auto trader soit gentil sur
les sectes je t'ai déjà dit je te le
répète les grandes personnes mes enfants
ils sont au lit alors là on va pas
embêter
trois ans de contrat il ya 600 millions
nets d'impôts que tu le veuilles ou tu
le vois 6 milliards si ces lignes on est
trois hommes il ya des trucs que tu sais
pas il y aura une fondation il est mais
tu connais rien t'as jamais fade hausse
y est ami donc tu connais pas tu as fait
tu as fait que faire des trucs là
j'en ai fait j'étais 253 fasse plaisir
ou encore faire que voilà tout écrivent
non mais plutôt que là mais moi je suis
jean tigana mais moi je veux pas semer
le bordel ensemble je veux pas que
mon souhait c'est bon maintenant c'est
vrai dans le nord sous les allez y peut
rien apporter des infos
tonné attentes a téléphoné à ton ami là
tu sais qui ça
tekken lui
mais je ne sais pas je suis là et on a
dix toiles s'est placée au gouvernement
parce que toi par là qui t'appelle je
peux pas le blairer
très bien qui est ton ami et je suis
d'accord avec les battues mais c'est bon
on parle d'un vrai qu'il ya même map et
je te le dis ton ami s'est
imaginé bois et moi j ai été moi il
aurait pris la tête dans la durée - mais
je te dis que tu sais très bien te faut
pas non ces masques jean yves a juste
dit je vais te la mettre moi j'aurais
mis donc
je te le dis si je vois je mettrais mois
donc ferme là oui j'imagine on suit
alors sûr qu'il ya trois ans ce sera six
cents jeunes à qui c'est une honte je
sais ça suscitait tout mais je vous
promets que l'on aimerait si tu sais
c'est bon bah on va on passe on peut
parler alors toi tu dis donc 50 millions
lui dit de changer pas d'avis
[Applaudissements]
donc de sens je suis donc sûr les trois
ans ce sera aux alentours de 600
millions nets d'impôts match tout
confondu sympa il ya une chose qui va
falloir enfin ce collage il c'est une
bonne nouvelle
c'est moi ça me choque pas c'est le
sportif qui soit le sportif le mieux
payé en france ou ailleurs monsieur ça
me choque pas parce qu'on parle pas trop
d'argent moi je regarde j'adore le
joueur j'adore le
j'adore l'homme il ya une autre chose
qui va falloir mettre en compte c'est
qu'il ya les jeux olympiques en 2024 ici
je pense que le président de la
république l'a appelé pour certainement
lui demander un petit peu ses attentes
et ce qu'il espérait
l'édile a dit à tout le monde c'est vrai
vous l'année à là que ben oui mais ah
oui mais le 7 ou le cesc est comme à
l'école c'était le petit rapporteur toi
c'est quoi
c'est
ces commandes n'y a pas une info
jamais eu d'infos tu as été partout tu
t'es fait virer par tous a jamais eu
d'infos tu as fait des émissions tapadas
photo raconte que des conneries donc
soit gentil laisse parler les hommes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
tous les arts dont la réponse de gilles
le paintball à savoir si ces anciens
delà des amis
tu l'a défendu la dernière fois je sais
très bien qui sait et tu sais que je
devrais je vous promets que je suivrai
ne ment pas mon pays je ne demande pas à
ses bons centres ou encore plus tu
montes en plus tu monte à bord allez on
va parler qu'ils aiment ça tu es bon tu
es pris en flagrant délit de mensonge et
de baston temps à l'appeler ça fait
alors guignols la banque les clubs
avec moi tu fumeras comment tu rentres
dans les stades avec moi pour moi si je
suis un clown d'anciens suffisante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
ton ami ton avis ton ami mais
je n'ai pas d'amis
mais moi c'est très vague et on donnera
pas son nom tant qu'à moi ça alors on
sait qui c'est tous les deux c'est
vrai par une dernière fois et c'est pour
ça que je vais dire est d'équiper c'est
toi mon ami allez c'est bon on a besoin
que le nom il a envie il a envie il en a
des envies de jouer les jeux olympiques
qui est dans sa ville et dans son pays
je note qu'elle est le capitaine et jeux
olympiques il avait fait un peu la
tronche parce qu'il n'avait pas été aux
jeux olympiques de vos derniers jeux
olympiques n'ai pas pu jouer parce que
le club n'avait pas libéré il ya un
quelque chose qui est symbolique sur les
jeux olympiques c'est le dernier
relayeur qui allume la vasque nation si
demain vous faites un sondage quel est
le sportif que vous mettez en premier
qu'il ya un mois la voilà donc question
c'est que ça a joué bah c'est symbolique
quand même assez ce qui appuie
symbolique donc est ce que ça sera lui
ben le feuilleton commence il ya deux
ans de feuilleton oui mais quand je vois
la balle et d'inde après accord a été
donné à killian papariga au real c'est
vrai c'est pas vrai à un warm est maudit
louin une parole donnée parce que ça on
en a beaucoup parlé tout au long du week
end est ce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
vrai mais qu'est ce que tu veux qu'il en
soit
je vais répondre sur ce que je la verrai
ce que bon ça va on peut essayer de
discuter sérieusement il peut pas y
avoir de près de pré accord signé ça
n'existe pas puisqu'il est libre à
partir du 1er janvier s'il signe à
partir du 1er janvier il est au real fm
et mobiles non maintenant ça c'est pas
grand chose ça se fait pas cesser il n'y
a pas de choses comme ça il surtout faut
pas que ça traîne ce genre de chose qui
ait des discussions qu'il ait vu perez
une fois dix fois vingt fois pas de
première classe et pour trois ans nayla
il a signé pour trois ans ici moi je
pense qu'il ya jamais eu de retour ni là
il a étudié les deux les deux choses il
a pesé le pour et le contre
contrairement à ce que disent les
espagnols qui disent quand même beaucoup
de conneries et depuis longtemps et ça
il va pas me contredire ça fait 30 ans
qui raconte que des conneries quand
maman et des espagnols surtout quand il
parle sur nous le problème va être
simple il a 23 ans dans trois ans il
aura 25 26 connaissent pas il n'est pas
éternel l'oréal bah il signera horaire
le réaliser on dit que c'était mort
d'accord il marsigny
non mais oui on va dire mais je vais me
marie avec
lui à toi de mémoire dans l'intérêt je
te le dis gilbert n'y aura pas au real
et chimie rage plus jamais au real
murcie mais nous dira en 2026 droit dans
la boîte qui vont toujours sortir dans
trois ans chez paul tu serais un club ce
sera peut-être à l'ehpad
[Applaudissements]
qui est dirigé par les socios c'est
pardonneront pas il a perdu cinq cent
mille abonnés sur installés alors la
censure mais non c'est pas vrai il irait
loin
3 d'horizon oublier va y aller je prends
bien tu verras rimer faut que tu te
trompes tu verras tu te trompe mais il a
peut-être raison même avant trois ans a
sauvé drm dans deux ans et rêve et pg à
prendre après l'ajout d'un tel cadeau
c'est qu'il ya en 2024
oui oui j'ai redit jls est posée avait
dit que grâce à la relation qu'il
entretenait avec macron depuis la
dernière coupe du monde macro l'avait
appelée il avait peut-être un peu voilà
aidé dans sa décision et est ce que
sarkozy aussi l'appeler ou pas je sais
pas non parce que sarkozy a aussi avalé
par et apparaît également que et on dit
également que rené coty
même papy insidieux vercingétorix
domaine relation avec le prince et la
passion il a aussi achevé notre action
quand même 10 me suis dit que c'est jean
ferrat il paraît que le pays veut
vraiment construire l'équipe autour
demba pays qui veulent peut-être moins
de stars internationales et plus de
joueurs français est ce que c'est vrai
c'est un peu ce qu'on veut tous les
amoureux du football s'il voit c'est ce
que je veux moi aussi c'est ce qu'on
veut maintenant est-ce qu'ils vont s qui
vont accéder à cette demande il ya que
qu'ils le savent maintenant comment ils
vont se comment ils vont gérer il paraît
que pochettino va sauter quel entraîneur
ils vont avoir à dire on n'y croit pas
du tout moi personnellement j'y crois
pas moi j'y crois
non du tout du tout sa une à boire ça
rien à voir non ça bouge postulat pas
une tranquille will et moi je t'aimais
je t'aime et tranquille
je te mets une petite pièce
bien
voilà ton billet je me tais
toi on fait des affaires non mais voilà
non j'ai rien à dire à favars
mais il ira ou n'ira jamais au real
d'accord c'est là je suis pas d'accord à
la tue pas d'accord avec toi mais
d'ifadem scapa saison 2 en mai mais tu
sais pas et la journée et vous comment
vous pouvez savoir la lauréate à 6h
colle aux fesses avril et moi y'a eu
beau mec qui m'ont dit je prendrai
jamais nous n'a je te le dis alors là
bas tu vois ma dis pas de bêtises teddy
libye dont cali le regret c'est vrai
qu'à ce stade il a dit je travaillerai
jamais que moi finalement bernard
montiel il a dit je travaillerai jamais
à côté de liège
aulas et ben regarde aujourd'hui les
conduira jamais je vous dis alors il
paraît aussi que ça va être un peu le
patron aussi dans le pack est vachement
euros ici au sein du goût du club où ça
c'est dû à d'autres genres sas et on lui
prête beaucoup d'attention il y va quand
même pas tout faire c'est pas un homme
orchestre un camp sur un essai d'abord
un joueur de foot qui a des gens des cas
les gens ici je m'en veux certainement
le meilleur joueur au monde à l'heure
actuelle avec non mais karim ben amor
j'espère qu'il aura le ballon d'or
certes il ya la ligue des champions
j'espère que le réal va gagner la ligue
des champions pour qui les diffusera
samedi oui j'y serai faux billets qui
malheureusement
cet homme j'y serai c'est moi qui lui
passe les billets
[Musique]
mais je veux pas dire le prix parce que
c'est une attaque atone
je vous dirais je voudrais dire merci
sam saddam on est d'accord le président
du directoire de canal mucem avoir
quatre places 4
il avait même pas la moitié d'une pour
moi
place maintenant à l'or parce que je
savais que mon fils
prenez deux places à 2 bahia monfils
plaskett de personnes il ya mon fils et
mon fils
avec un ami et son fils également ça va
j'ai regardé à la télé non c'était pas
là mais
c'était toi l'ami des quotas
qu
[Applaudissements]
est ce que j avais voilà bon merci à
gilles mercier est ce que tu as un truc
a ajouté mme jean savy donc mais je vais
attendre la sortie peut-être ah oui
j'attends quelqu'un la sortie
qu'est-ce que vous avez tous les deux
parce que puisque j'ai dirigé la vérité
je n'avais jamais vu j'avais jamais
adressé la passe dans ces relations
auraient pu nous donnera la réputation
parce que sinon on va dire un truc c'est
que je ne supporte pas ça voilà je te le
dis moi je juge sur pièce moi j le jeu
comprend plus que c'est un très bon
chroniqueur est jolie vache moyens et je
déteste les mecs qui sont directs a fait
sa priorité des a priori six mois alors
tu me juger sur des a priori tout ce
qu'on dit sur moi et battu serait pas là
c'est en quoi donc arrête de juger on
voit comme ailier moi je vais voter ben
là c'est un mec que j'aime bien voilà
c'est tout après on verra bien on a le
talent ce cas qu'est-ce qui te dérange
est rappelé qu'il est un peu dérangée
travailler sur le bonhomme après la bête
en espagne avec cette époque qui t'ont
dis ça mais pas
chez tes potes et je sais très bien
qu'ils étaient chez toi et c'est moi qui
vais le
tartare être parce que tu vas finir ça
va mal finir
je te disais je sais très bien qui t'a
pas mais je ne sais pas de qui minent
actuellement comme un arracheur de coûts
c'est pas possible